Поки триває війна в Україні, більшість чоловіків
не можуть виїжджати за кордон.
Дехто готовий на все, аби цю заборону оминути. Тоді як інші - свідомо відмовляються від мирного життя за межами України.
У нас тут безпека, замки. Ось тут я і живу.
Владислав показує, де живе від початку березня. Він - юрист за фахом, але з перших днів війни разом із друзями приєднався до київської тероборони.
Хлопець працював у міжнародній компанії. Роботодавець ще до початку повномасштабного вторгнення пропонував переїхати працювати в Британію
або Німеччину. Влад відмовився, каже, що хоче будь-що залишатися в Україні.
Писав кандидатську дисертацію і у мене не стояло питання, що мене можуть мобілізувати до війни. Але в перші дні, коли я побачив, які жахи відбуваються,
що дійсно сталося, на нашу країну напали, я зрозумів, що не хочу і не зможу сидіти і просто продовжувати звичайне життя.
Зараз Владислав проходить бойові навчання, вечорами компонує треки на синтезаторі, і не шкодує про свій вибір.
До заборони виїзду за кордон хлопець ставиться неоднозначно.
З одного боку у нас є інтереси національної безпеки, що нам треба забезпечити мобілізаційний план, і як на мене це єдина причина,
чому може бути заборона виїзду з країни. З іншого боку, я бачу ситуацію, що зараз немає кризи кадрів.
Цьому молодому чоловікові 30 років. Він виїхав за кордон після того, як вступив до польського вишу. Хлопець представився Олегом,
попросив не показувати його обличчя і змінити голос, адже переймається через свою безпеку. З початком війни він втратив роботу в сфері шоубізнесу.
У мене остання зарплата була шість місяців тому, і в Україні всі ці шість місяців я намагався знайти, чим займатися. При цьому життя в Україні постійно
дорожчало, зарплати ставали все меншими й меншими.
Олег розповідає, що разом із другом вирішив отримати польський диплом, щоб знайти роботу в Європі. Обрав магістерську програму, склав іспити, вступив
на навчання. Чоловік каже, що не зміг би служити в армії.
Я в принципі за своєю натурою антимілітарист. Я не можу, мене до смерті лякають автомати. Я розумію, що це війна,
це жорстоко, дуже багато людей втрачають усе, жертвують усім. Але ми не повинні ігнорувати людину, її особливості, виходячи з цього.
Олег називає заборону чоловікам виїжджати за кордон сексизмом. Водночас, запевняє: якщо обмеження скасують, то готовий повернутися в Україну.
Я їхав з Києва зі сльозами на очах, з повним відчуттям, що я залишаю там досить благополучне життя. І коли я їхав, у мене було відчуття,
що я їду не з власної волі, а я внутрішньо відчуваю, що мене змусили виїхати.
Олег також розповідає, що на кордоні попри довідки з військкомату й польського університету, чоловіка і його друга пропустили лише після кількагодинних суперечок.
За словами Олега, чимало хто підробляє студентські документи, тому прикордонники до таких подорожуючих ставляться насторожено.
Держприкордонслужба регулярно повідомляє про затримання українців
з підробленими студентськими документами.
Люди сплачують за липові папери від півтори до п'яти тисяч доларів.
За підроблення документів передбачене покарання
до 5 років позбавлення волі, за ухилення від призову - до трьох років.
Маріуполець, який представився Олександром і теж спілкувався з нами телефоном, шість років працював моряком.
З початком війни разом з рідними виїхав з Маріуполя в центральну Україну, залишився без роботи.
Олександр каже, що неможливість працювати доводила його до відчаю.
Коли в Україні ти розумієш, що такої зарплати немає і не буде, і ти нічого окрім моря не вмієш - на березі працювати і жити,
то це просто перетворюється для моряка на в'язницю. Були думки про самогубство, і доводилося користуватися
безкоштовними послугами психолога, щоб знайти вихід.
Чоловік виїхав до окупованого Мелітополя, звідти - до Криму. Каже, що дорогою бачив, як машини підривалися на мінах.
За словами Олександра, після переходу кордону в анексований Росією Крим, він побачив десятки автобусів до Литви, Латвії, Польщі.
Вони перетинають Кримський міст і прямують до Європи територією Росії.
Від 300 до 500 доларів, щоб доїхати. І вони брали попутників і просто везли їх, через кордон, через усю цю величезну територію -
може, близько двох тисяч кілометрів. І так я потрапив додому. Скоро, через кілька тижнів у мене посадка на борт корабля -
це мій дім, я знову працюватиму і повернуся до життя.
Більше я навряд чи повернуся в Україну.
Олександра обурює рішення української влади заборонити чоловікам виїзд за кордон. На його думку, воювати мають люди з відповідними навичками.
Я вважаю, що дати людині зброю і відправити її воювати - це абсолютно безглуздо. Дайте людині, яка не вміє користуватися зброєю,
небезпечну смертельну зброю, і вона покалічить
і своїх друзів, і себе, і оточуючих.
Данило вправно чистить свій АК-47. Нині він боєць тероборони, а до 24 лютого - айтішник, який ніколи не тримав у руках зброю.
24 лютого я прокидаюся о 9 ранку, дивлюся, що на вулиці багато людей, чую вибухи, я зрозумів, що відбулося, я просто зібрав речі і пішов до військкомату.
І я пам'ятаю, коли закривав двері квартири, я вже тоді морально налаштувався, що, можливо, до кінця тижня я вже не доживу.
Я навіть пам'ятаю перший день, коли я прийшов, мені показали, як користуватися автоматом,
і це було приблизно за дві-три години до того, як ми поїхали в Гостомель.
Данило так само отримував пропозиції виїхати за кордон до початку вторгнення. До цього він чотири роки прожив у Шотландії,
але повернувся в Україну й більше не хотів виїжджати.
Там було дуже круто, шотландці насправді дуже привітні люди і я себе відчував, як вдома, там. Але особливо коли почався Майдан,
я зрозумів, що моя країна рухається в тому напрямку, в якому я хотів її бачити.
Хлопець зізнається, що у школі його називали слабким. Тепер побратими кажуть, що він чемпіон з підтягувань на перекладині.
На думку Данила, головне - мотивація.
Мені здається, що все потрібно робити з бажанням. Тобто коли ми це все будували, чи там в умовах, у яких ми жили - це було важко,
але я ні миті не шкодував, тому що розумів, що це потрібно робити. Але я просто розумію, що можливо для когось це буде складно,
і це вибір людини, чи готова вона піти на це.
Нині у Верховній Раді зареєстровано законопроєкт, за яким можуть розширити перелік категорій чоловіків, яким дозволено виїзд за кордон.
Зокрема, пропонують дозволити перетин кордону айтішникам і людям, які мають робочі контракти в інших країнах.
Водночас Володимир Зеленський раніше наголошував, що захист Вітчизни є обов'язком громадян України.
Тому, за словами президента, обмеження на виїзд за кордон скасують уже після завершення воєнного стану.